so are you guys going to Adam's wedding
why is this the biggest like question
everybody said I'm not going to that
[__] [__] I didn't beat it on the bush
I ain't going wouldn't it be awkward and
my dream is all show goddamn tickets
[__] with this [__] man
I'm going look he got me doing all type
of [__] over here bro huh I did a
reverse super Uno uh we still go to
Italy have a good time I love Italy it's
in Italy yeah
let's go down and still
I'm ready we're talking spots we can do
some shopping hey how hilarious would it
be if you guys went to Italy during the
same time
same hotel and you're like hey we're
just we could drive past the venues
[Laughter]
you think which are passive in you
everybody gets scared oh I mean but if
we did go would it be a problem I feel
like y'all should go I don't but but
like we just joking now like I don't
know I got my ticket we
Adam my mind might change by may 19.
this is all jokes at the end of the day
but I still look at them like a homeboy
right you feel me like if he he can text
me he didn't text me the other day he
could text me I could text him and [__]
like that like it ain't no bad blood
like [__] appreciate him you know for
we wouldn't even be doing what we doing
right now if he didn't put the battery
in our back so
um we always gonna have respect for him
when he come down to that and thank you
go to the wedding
yeah
there'd be no reason why you weren't
invited Heather wants to go if Heather
says if Heather says we're going then we
can still go who wouldn't want to go
it's an excuse to go to Italy I know
it'd be really weird if you guys went
anyway and everyone was at the same
hotel and you're like oh yeah we already
bought our tickets but you know we're
going uh we're going to I doesn't I
doesn't want to talk business when we
get there yeah no business talk we just
go just have some fun you're like we got
to get the boys back together man I feel
like it'd be natural for you guys to
also have Adam as one of your first
guests
wow I didn't think about that why not
bro clear up all the [__] you know
because I feel like you guys genuinely
probably I mean you guys like you just
said you have love for Adam yeah the
feelings Mutual I do [__] that we giving
the beef going
like I do think like like Tyrell like
you were saying I think it's like a big
learning curve with all this [__] yeah
because like I feel like no jumper had
like evolved into something it had never
been before so I'm sure like you know
there's a learning curve on how to deal
with all these personality I mean the
[__] got fired on camera bro you
know what I'm saying like that
how do you feel like that you know what
I'm saying as a business owner right now
here doing content like would you would
have you know ever did any of that
there's so much stuff that has happened
over there me and Eric my producer we
talk about it all the time yeah like it
ain't worth it it's just not it's not
would you like you know would you ever
as a boss go and fire Eric like look
Eric this camera you the camera rolling
Eric your ass fire get your well I mean
I kind of fired him before but not like
that I was like hey man you want to be a
famous photographer I need somebody who
wants to be a famous podcast producer
are you throwing shots on my boys
[Applause]
see this is how we do it I see what
you're doing
you're gonna be a stirred up [__] with
our media
[__] oh my God I'm honorary Armenian I
don't know if you know me too yeah of
course I've been to three Armenian
weddings and a Mexican
oh my wife's Mexican okay aren't you no
I'm not mad we've already gone through
this you know this is Hispanic I have
two Mexican children damn she be
whooping your ass in there huh
[__] your ass up she be on the
croissant [__] in there
man no
no no no
call yourself
she definitely I don't know Christian
[__] oh my God and it's funny because
that [__] is real because they came here
like two weeks ago that's just real real
and right there she carved her [__]
their initials into the table right
there oh that's crazy she was like this
like pissed and like I'm like what
[__] it it's survive property damage but
like an hour prior to them getting here
like well they were here an hour prior
to the interview starting they were just
yelling at each other while he was
getting his hair cut in the other
building I'm sorry Kev that's probably
something that's probably the best
vagina on this planet to continue to
deal with that I don't even throw I'ma
be honest
let me give you some here [__] people
like oh my God I forget everything I'm
gonna be I think I think that wipe it
away I think being being near them for a
couple of hours it made me kind of
realize like well now that she's sober
it feels a little like I don't know man
it feels a little manipulative on the
blue face side I feel like he's kind of
running up the numbers right now because
he kind of knows like let's go viral no
no I said it in the interview I'm like
yo she's more popping than you he's like
yeah she signed to me I want her to be
more popular
whoa
oh so he's running it up I think that's
more of what's happening so it's not
real no it is real but I mean she's
pregnant God I mean it's a sad situation
I think that whole thing like it's like
kind of what is it worth it the numbers
the money but yeah some of the no jumper
[__] that happened like I definitely
would not name something
talk about it
um I mean the firing thing you know I
think
um I just think that like I was telling
Adam the same [__] like lie to me Lush
no sometimes
um just some of the like I feel like uh
we would talk about like it felt like
sometimes he would just be having random
gang members on that don't really ain't
doing [__] but are gang members I don't
know yeah there was like a little like
point in time it was an error there was
like an era like the [__] Mack era where
it felt like every other guy on the show
was fascinated with Street coacher and
it was like uh so and so on being a
something something [__] and going to
jail and being white yeah like no
substance there I mean but what the [__]
are you supposed to do when no artists
gonna come through there you know and it
works right like yes like like to me
like I can't even well like to me the
the no jumper thing has worked it is way
bigger than what I'm doing but you know
for for me like just a lot of the like
uh the [__] that happened with house
phone you know I think was was uh
terrible it was mishandled flagrantly
even even if it wasn't meant to be Miss
handle flake really like
like I was telling him I was like bro
that that wouldn't even that wasn't even
a sniff the YouTube that wouldn't even
got
you can't even load that up and that's
and that's where accountability comes
into play right